STEPHEN GREENBLATT: Shakespeare was the creator of mass entertainments.
He was interested in reaching a very large number of people in his world.
And he thought professionally about how to reach those people where they lived,
as it were, in their deepest way.
I've thought about Shakespeare for many, many years.
And I remain amazed by his intuitive ideas as to where the power would lie.
He thought in Merchant of Venice about the relationship
between those who are in the inside and those
who are on the outside, between those who are comfortably at the center
and those who are the pariahs, the hated and spat upon ones.
So he looked, for example, to women who didn't obey the rules,
as in Taming of the Shrew.
He looked to the relationship between whites and blacks
and to thinking about sex anxieties in Othello.
He thought about what to do with very old people in families,
as in King Lear.
He had what seems to us at this distance 400 years later
to be an unerring instinct for thinking about what might still concern us
even though our concerns are quite different from those
that governed Shakespeare's time.
And that's part of the secret of his work.
He was a master of metamorphosis.
He allowed his plays to go out into the world and change their meanings.
And 400 years from now, though we can scarcely
imagine what the world will be like, I think
we can be confident that there will be people, many, many people, who
will still respond in their own ways to what Shakespeare left them.
This is part of the mystery and part of the thrill of Shakespeare's work.